[موسيقى]
الدوله من اول ما اجوا هالمهاجرين ان كان
اكراد لبنان او كان اخواننا الفلسطينيه او
من اي الجاليات كلها اجت احتضنتهم واعطتهم
اقامات
وجبرتهم انه يشتغلوا كنا شفنا هلا مجتمع
غير غير هلا اللي موجود هون بس ولكن اليوم
حسب يعني
اليوم في مثلا طلع قانون بالالفين هو اسمه
القانون اللي طلع جمهوريه المانيا
الاتحاديه
انه انت لك حظ ثاني اي دوله هيدا القانون
تطبق على ناس وما تطبق علينا
تطبق على غير جماعه واعطوهم اقامات ومن
لما اعطوهم اقامات كمان نجحوا بحياتهم
وعملوا هيدوله
[موسيقى]
لدينا العديد من المشاكل فيما يخص الجيل
الثالث والذين يعيشون بطريقه عاديه مثل
الالمان لكنهم يواجهون غالبا مشكلات لانهم
ورثوا اقامه مؤقته ولا يملكون الجنسيه
الالمانيه لذلك لا يتمتعون بحق الانتخاب
او الزواج في المانيا فهم يعتبرون اشخاصا
من درجه ثانيه في الواقع يصير هذا الجيل
الثالث على الطريق الصحيح ولكن نحن من
نعرقلهم في الاندماج لان قانون الاجانب
يمنحهم فتره اقامه مؤقته فقط اما
الاشكاليه الثانيه تتمثل في ان هذا الجيل
الثالث بدوره ينقل الاقامه المؤقته للجيل
الرابع هذا ما يعني ان هؤلاء الاطفال لا
يتمتعون بجواز او بحقوق
[موسيقى]